alle Platzwechsel erledigt dann
gebe ich das Wort an Julia verlinken für
Bündnis 90 Sekunden
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen
wir haben im Augenblick zwei
Herausforderungen im Gasmarkt das eine
sind die deutlich gestiegenen Preise und
das andere ist dass uns in Europa
weniger Gas zur Verfügung steht als in
den letzten Jahren
zum ersten dazu hat die
expertin-kommission bis Montag früh um
sechs es ging fast schon die Sonne auf
an einem Zwischenbericht gearbeitet
herzlichen Dank an dieser Stelle an alle
die daran mitgewirkt haben auch an den
vielen Mitarbeiterinnen die mit dabei
waren bis zum Ende und auch im
Hintergrund sehr viel dafür geleistet
haben
und Tatsache ist es werden in diesem
Zwischenbericht Instrumente für alle
gaskundinnen für alle fernwärmekundinnen
vorgeschlagen das heißt sowohl die
privaten Haushalte als auch die
Bäckereien als auch die Sportstätten die
Krankenhäuser und natürlich auch für die
Industrie gibt es in diesem Bericht
Vorschläge was die Politik jetzt tun
kann um groß zu entlasten und die
Entlastung sind vor allem für diejenigen
wichtig die gerade in eine besonders
schwierige Situation zu geraten drohen
und auch hierfür sind konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht worden sind diese
Vorschläge werden jetzt von der
Bundesregierung geprüft und daran sind
zahlreiche Ministerien beteiligt denn
selbstverständlich sind hier auch viele
Ressorts betroffen die dafür jetzt
umsetzungsprüfungen übernehmen müssen ob
Gesetze möglicherweise genau so oder ein
bisschen anders realisiert werden können
und ich glaube es ist allen allen in den
Ministerien aber natürlich auch uns hier
im Bundestag bewusst es braucht eine
schnelle Unterstützung und deswegen
werden wir das auch so schnell ist
irgendwie auf den Weg bringen
und um Missverständnisse zu vermeiden
allein dass derzeit teure Gas zu
subventionieren das wird nicht
ausreichen in der aktuellen schwierigen
Situation denn die begrenzte Menge wird
dadurch nicht mehr dass man es
subventioniert im Gegenteil wenn alle
genau dieselbe Menge verbrauchen wie in
der Vergangenheit dann könnte es ein
Problem geben denn leider sind
zahlreiche Lebens- und
Wirtschaftsbereiche bei uns noch
abhängig vom Erdgas viel zu viele
Gebäude werden mit gasbeheizt der
Umstieg auf erneuerbare Wärme auf
Energieeffizienz ist in den letzten
Jahren viel zu langsam vorangegangen und
zahlreiche Menschen arbeiten mit
Hochdruck daran mehr Wärmepumpen
einzubauen Windräder zu planen
Solaranlagen auf die Dächer zu bringen
und all das ist ein wichtiger Beitrag
dafür ganz herzlichen Dank aber man kann
eben auch nicht alles von heute auf
morgen herbeizaubern
alle Speicher in Deutschland sind gut
gefüllt auch dafür vielen Dank an
diejenigen die daran beteiligt waren
Wirtschaft und Regierung alle die daran
mitgearbeitet haben aber gefüllte
Speicher allein reicht nicht um sich
entspannt zurückzulehnen denn hier
kälter der Winter wird je mehr geheizt
wird
desto weniger Energie ist dann
möglicherweise für die Industrie zur
Verfügung in den nächsten Monaten und
auch das betrifft dann auch die Menschen
die dort arbeiten ich hoffe dass die
Bundesnetzagentur als lastverteiler
nicht entscheiden wird oder entscheiden
muss Gas zu rationieren sodass große
Unternehmen in einer gasmangelage ihre
Produktion oder ein Teil davon
Herunterfahren müssen deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir kommunizieren dass die
Lage ernst ist dass alle einen Beitrag
leisten können und auch sollten um Wärme
einzusparen und die Kommission will
genau deswegen im Abschlussbericht Ende
Oktober ausführlich dazu Empfehlungen
abgeben das zum Thema Energieeffizienz
und Energie sparen jetzt politisch
sinnvoll ist und dazu gehören auch
Investitionen denn Investitionen in die
Transformation in der Industrie in den
Wasserstoff hochlaufen in
energiesparende Technologien in
Gebäudesanierung in die erneuerbaren
Energien das ist die beste Versicherung
gegen hohe Energiepreise
und klar ist
die Investitionen sind wichtig und es
gibt auch kleine Dinge die jetzt
parallel von vielen gemacht werden
können denn kleine Dinge die in der
Summe einen riesigen Unterschied machen
können
ein weiteres wichtiges Argument ist wenn
wir den Verbrauch reduzieren dann hat
das auch preisdämpfende Wirkung und das
hilft dann auch allen uns gemeinsam
wieder bei dieser Herausforderung bei
der Entlastung und ich finde eine Sache
die braucht auch noch mehr
Aufmerksamkeit wir reden viel über
Verfügbarkeit des Gases die Preise vom
Erdgas und so weiter und das ist auch
wichtig dass wir hier auch den Menschen
Sicherheit geben und sagen keiner wird
allein gelassen wir unterstützen alle
bleiben aber beim Thema es geht jetzt in
der Aktuellen Stunde hier im Bundestag
genau und darum nämlich um die
Vorschläge der
gaspreiskommission es steht gerade am
Rednerpult Julia verlinken für die
Grünen weiterhin in einer sich täglich
verschärfen den Klimakrise und auch
deswegen ist es sinnvoll wenn wir hier
mit der Transformation schnell
voranschreiten vielen Dank
ja Julia verlinken hatte fünf Minuten
wir haben vor zwei drei Minuten hier
angefangen in der Aktuellen Stunde die
Redezeiten ja begrenzt alle fünf Minuten
jetzt als nächster am Rednerpult Andreas
Jung für die Union
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Kollegin
Dr Verlinden es muss schnell gehandelt
werden
keiner wird alleine gelassen kein Bürger
kein Betrieb das waren in etwa die Worte
von Bundeskanzler Olaf scholzers am 22
juli seine Pressekonferenz gegeben hat
und seine Botschaft gegeben hat Jul
never walk alone
das ist richtig zitiert und es ist auch
richtig zitiert wenn ich dann dazu sage
und dann hat er aber die gasumlage dort
vorgeschlagen die die Preise verteuert
hätte hätte Olaf Scholz am 22 juli des
klare Signal gegeben wir lassen keinen
allein und deshalb kommt eine
Preisbremse und dafür setzen wir eine
Kommission ein dann würde die
gaspreisbremse uns in diesem Winter
helfen können und nicht aus dem März
oder April
und das ist unser Punkt wir haben
Respekt von der Arbeit der Kommission
und wir werden sehr konstruktiv diese
Vorschläge bearbeiten und werden darauf
drängen dass die gaspreisbremse schnell
unbürokratisch und ein Gesamtkonzept
umgesetzt wird aber fest steht damit
auch die Kommission ist zum Ergebnis
gehören man braucht ein Vorlauf von vier
Monaten und deshalb werden wir die
gaspreisbremse in diesem Winter nicht
haben und deshalb schlägt sie ja für den
Winter für die Zeit davor eine Brücke
vor mit einer Einmalzahlung die je
länger man sich damit beschäftigt mehr
Fragen aufwirft als beantwortet der soll
Bezug genommen werden auf dem September
im Sept auf die Abschläge dort da sind
aber viele der Preiserhöhungen noch gar
nicht angekommen am gewesen kann eine
Einmalzahlung für den September
tatsächlich durch die Zeit mindestens
September Oktober November Dezember
Januar Februar März vielleicht kommt die
Preisbremse ja erst im April das ist ein
sehr sportlicher Plan hört man aus der
Kommission bleibt die Geldzahlung
eigentlich gleich hoch egal ob die
Bremse im März kommt oder im April da
sind viele Fragen unbeantwortet und die
Regierung hat durch ihr verspätetes
handeln die Kommission in diese von ihr
auch selbst sogenannte und zumutbare
Situation gebracht
wir fordern das ein Gesamtkonzept gibt
die gaspreisbremse ist das eine wir
erwarten das jetzt auch Vorschläge macht
werden für die strompreisbremse das ist
gemeinsam umgesetzt wird wir erwarten
das keine Schieflage gibt zwischen den
Menschen die mit Gas heizen die Strom
nutzen und denen die noch mit Öl heizen
oder die mit Öl heizen und die auf
pelletpellets gesetzt haben und wir
brauchen trotz Bremsen bei Gas und bei
Strom brauchen wir bessere Unterstützung
für Normalverdiener das was
vorgeschlagen wird bedeutet ja dass
trotzdem sich die Gasrechnung im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr mehr als
verdoppeln wird
das können Menschen mit einem geringen
Einkommen nicht tragen und da ist es
richtig dass beim Wohngeld etwas gemacht
wird diese Menschen brauchen das aber es
gibt Menschen die bekommen kein Wohngeld
auch nach ihre Form kein Wohngeld aber
haben trotzdem ein so geringes Einkommen
dass sie eine
Preissteigerung die mehr als eine
Verdoppelung ist nicht werden tragen
können deshalb muss diese Bremse ergänzt
werden durch bessere Hilfen für
Normalverdiener darauf werden wir in den
Beratungen drängen
und wir halten es für falsch was die
Bundesregierung angekündigt hat die
Bundesregierung hat angekündigt dass
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm ist
heute morgen im energieausschuss
angekündigt dann wird zum Jahresende
eingestellt nach allem was wir kennen
haben wir nicht die Erwartung dass allen
Betrieben die jetzt in Existenzen und
sind denn jetzt geholfen werden muss die
jetzt die Preisexplosion haben dass
denen durch das was kommen könnte im
März oder April dass das diese Fragen
beantwortet wir setzen auf die Zusage
von Robert Habeck er hat angekündigt
dass Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm wird so geändert das
ist ein leichteren Zugang gibt dass auch
Bäckereien dass der Mittelstand dass der
Handwerk daraus Unterstützung bekommen
kann dann nehmen wir den Ministern wir
nehmen die Bundesregierung beim Wort
diese Fragen werden nicht beantwortet
durch eine Preisbremse die vielleicht im
März oder April kommt
und bei den Pellets da haben Menschen in
Pellets investiert mit Ermunterung der
Politik mit Zuschüssen der KfW und die
rechnen es uns vor ich kenne die Zahlen
von einer Bäckerei die haben
Preissteigerungen die mehr als eine
Verdopplung sind die eine Verdreifachung
bedeuten die diese Betriebe in eine
existenzbedrohende Situation bringt da
ist bisher die Antwort der
Bundesregierung für die machen wir nicht
dabei kann es nicht bleiben da droht
eine Schieflage und deshalb trinken wir
auf ein Gesamtkonzept und zu diesem
Gesamtkonzept muss auch dazu gehören
dass es Angebot erweitert wird und
deshalb fordern wir Sie auf Beenden sie
ihren Streit in der Koalition treffen
sie es endlich eine Entscheidung die das
umsetzt was ihre eigenen experten
fordern ein dringender Rat der Experten
der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber nutzen Sie
jetzt endlich alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung Biomasse Deckel ist
abgeräumt bei der Kohle muss es jetzt
schneller vorangehen und bei der
Kernenergie brauchen wir eine klare
Entscheidung dass das was möglich ist
für diesen Winter für die Krise jetzt
gemacht wird ihr Streit belastet das
Vertrauen in die Handlungsfähigkeit des
Staates deshalb brauchen wir da ist eine
Entscheidung vielen Dank
fordert hier Andreas Jung für die
cdu/csu-fraktion er ist der Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie oder hören wir
mal was die Ampel bzw einer der
ampelkoalitionäre für die SPD in dem
Fall zu sagen hat Matthias Mirsch der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD
Andreas Jung ich finde das vollkommen in
Ordnung dass die
Opposition natürlich Fragen stellt
Kritik äußert aber gerade die
cdu/csu-fraktion sollte sehr vorsichtig
sein wenn man hier von den Lösungen
spricht im März haben sie hier an dieser
Stelle gefordert mit ihrem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden mit ihrem
Parteivorsitzenden das von der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein
einseitiges Gaseinbau gegenüber Russland
ausgesprochen werden soll wir würden
jetzt nicht mehr über Bremsen reden
sondern wir hätten Versorgungsprobleme
die ins Eingemachte ins existenzielle
gehen würden
und deswegen muss man vorsichtig sein
wenn man hier Kritik äußert aber ich
finde es hervorragend dass sie jetzt
hier sagen sie wollen sich konstruktiv
an diesen Vorschlägen beteiligen und ich
will das im Namen der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion sagen unser Dank
gilt den Expertinnen und Experten die
aus unserer Sicht eine sehr sehr gute
Grundlage für unsere weitergehende
Beratung aufgestellt haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es ist immer so wenn eine Lösung
schnell wirken soll dann wird man in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland bei 80
Millionen Menschen immer Fälle finden wo
man sagen was ist nicht gerecht aber das
erste was uns jetzt wichtig ist ist den
Menschen Sicherheit zu geben und das
steht im Vordergrund
und dass wir in der Industrie aufgrund
der Strukturen einer einfachere
Möglichkeit ab 1.1.23 diese Bremse
wirken lassen und dann vom ersten
dritten bis zum mindestens ersten
vierten 24 allen die hier in Deutschland
einen Anschluss haben diese Sicherheit
geben dieser Eingriff ins System war der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion ganz wichtig und
wir sind froh dass die
Expertenkommission diese Ansatz mit
übernommen hat
aber es ist ebenso richtig und Herr
junge ich gebe Ihnen ausdrücklich recht
wir müssen gucken was wir dazwischen
machen und das ist der Winter und
deswegen ist es aus meiner Sicht ein
Ansatz dass die Kommission sagt wir
wollen im Dezember an den
Abschlagszahlungen ansetzen und der
Staat soll diese übernehmen aber es
stellen sich weitere Fragen zum Beispiel
was ist mit Januar und Februar ist es
eigentlich gerechtfertigt das vor dem
Hintergrund der dann klar
gesetzgeberisch festgelegten Bremsen
überhaupt noch siebenfache achtfache
Abschläge von den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern verlangt werden können seitens
der Versorger auch das müssen wir jetzt
im weiteren beratungsablauf klären
und ich halte es genauso für
gerechtfertigt dass man überlegt bedarf
es weitere flankierender Maßnahmen
zwischen Dezember und März 2023 auch dem
werden wir uns stellen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und genauso ist es aus
unserer Sicht natürlich ein großes Thema
dass wir
augenmaßnahmen greifen lassen wollen die
Frage stellen wie ist das eigentlich mit
dem mit der Gerechtigkeit hinter dem
Anschluss wir haben das große Problem
dass die versorge augenblicklich das
nicht wissen sie wissen nicht ob es ein
Einfamilienhaus ist ein Mehrfamilienhaus
eine Villa jemand der da drin wohnt zu
fünft zu zweit Reich Arm das ist diesen
Versorgern nicht bekannt und deswegen
finden wir es richtig dass die
Kommission auch auf diesen
gerechtigkeitsaspekt einer Antwort
findet indem sie sagen die Besteuerung
dessen was dort gezahlt wird ab einem
gewissen Steuersatz wäre eine
Möglichkeit auch darüber müssen wir
jetzt beraten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich sage aber auch es kann weitergehen
wenn wir von März bis April 24
mehrere Monate fast über ein Jahr diese
Bremse wirken lassen kann man auch
überlegen wenn weitere Daten vorhanden
sind ob in dieser Bremse in dieser
Bremse eine Obergrenze eingeführt wird
so dass es bei bestimmten
Einkommensklassen gar nicht mehr zu
einer Forderung bzw Förderung kommt auch
darüber werden wir reden müssen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja es ist auch zu Recht angesprochen
worden wenn auch siebenfache achtfache
Steigerungen die Ausnahme sind aber die
die auf Öl gesetzt haben die die auf
Pellets gesetzt haben sollen auch nicht
alleine gelassen werden und deswegen
werden wir im parlamentarischen
Verfahren auch diese Gruppe in den Fokus
nehmen und hier Härten auch abfedern
auch dazu hat die Kommission Vorschläge
gemacht über härtefallfonds und weiteren
Einrichtungen die wir als Grundlage
sehen um auch diese Gruppe tatsächlich
in Sicherheit zu bringen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das was die
Kommission vorgeschlagen hat ist aus
unserer Sicht ein richtiger Schritt den
Zusammenhalt in dieser schwierigen Zeit
zu organisieren vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
aber wenn man Matthias Mirsch zugehört
hat hier dann gibt es auch noch einige
offene Fragen sie zu beantworten sind
die Bundesregierung hat angekündigt eine
gaspreisbremse so rasch wie möglich
umzusetzen aber dann braucht es ja eben
noch das parlamentarische Verfahren und
viele Fragen die da noch geklärt werden
müssen
[Applaus]
ja während der Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen bevor ich loslege ein kurzer
Realitätscheck wieder mal heute letzte
verfügbare Daten des fraunhofinstitutes
Wind liefert eineinhalb Gigawatt
kennenlänge 4 und sie verbrennen gerade
wieder für 9 Gigawatt Gas zur
Stromerzeugung das an die Kollegen die
meinen dass die Erneuerbaren die Lösung
der Energiekrise wären die erste
Empfehlung der Expertenkommission liegt
also vor und wie zu erwarten Land der
Regierung mit massiven Einsatz von
Steuergeldern die Probleme zu lösen die
es ohne sie natürlich nicht gäbe bis zu
200 Milliarden sollen erst aufgewindet
werden um Gas und Fernwärme wieder in
den Bereich des bezahlbaren zu bringen
und die Unternehmen sowie die Bürger zu
entlasten ob diese Summe ausreichen wird
um die Zeichen des energiepolitischen
Versagens der Regierung zu begleichen
ist dabei vollkommen offen
das gilt für diese Maßnahmen ist auch
gar nicht vorhanden und es wird über
weitere Schulden refinanziert ganz egal
welche Umschreibung dafür auch gewählt
werden wird der Schattenhaushalt im
betrügerischer Absicht auch gern
Sondervermögen genannt von nun 360
Milliarden Euro wird bei größer sein als
diese Summe im bundeshaushaltsplan und
das schlimmste dabei ist sie verbrennen
dieses Geld der Bürger völlig Ziel und
orientierungslos sie geben Milliarden
von eurer aus für Instrumente von denen
sie nicht wissen ob sie funktionieren
Prinzip Hoffnung und blinder teurer
Aktionismus der wieder einmal nur die
Symptome mildern soll anstatt an die
Wurzeln des Problems zu gehen und diese
Wurzel heißt ihre Energiewende ist
krachend gescheitert
über 500 Milliarden Euro mussten sich
die Stromverbraucher für Wind und
photovoltaiksubventionen aus den Taschen
ziehen lassen deren energiebeitrag im
kommenden Winter irgendwo zwischen
vernachlässigbar und unzuverlässig
schwanken wird und als ob diese zylose
Verschwendung von Geld für das Millionen
Bürger hart arbeiten müssen noch nicht
ausreicht verspotten sie die
unermüdlichen Steuerzahler dieses Landes
noch mit hochnäsigen Ratschlägen zu
Waschlappen Pullovern und wie man sich
Wasser sparend in der Dusche erleichtert
nicht nur dass sie die Bürger berauben
sie machen sich über die Bürger auch
noch lustig
aber kommen wir zu dem wenigen was wir
von ihren Programmen wissen den
offiziell ist eigentlich noch gar nichts
die Gasrechnung des Dezembers soll
übernommen werden und ab dem Frühjahr
irgendwann wenn die Heizperiode vorbei
ist wollen sie Teile des Gaspreises für
private und ab Januar für die Industrie
Deckel soweit so wenig ihr Vorhaben die
Rechnung für Dezember zu übernehmen
zeugt aber schon von ihrem mangelnden
Verständnis der Sachlage während die
Gasverbraucher und Fernwärme Nutzer
einmalig und völlig unzureichend einen
Teil ihrer kostenersetzt bekommen den
Nutzer von Öl und Pelletheizungen
komplett leer aus es wurde angesprochen
und dabei sind auch in diesem Bereichen
die Brennstoffkosten stark gestiegen Öl
hat sich verdoppelt und Pellets haben
sich verdreifacht aber was ist jetzt
eigentlich mit den von ihnen viel
angepriesen Wärmepumpen auch Strom ist
extrem teuer geworden und jetzt können
wir zu einer Perversität ihres
Vorschlages denn Strom wird signifikant
aus Gas erzeugt das heißt der
gasverstromer kann seine
dezemberrechnung bei Minister Lindner
einreichen aber der so subventile Strom
wird im vollen Umfang an die Stromkunden
weitergegeben dort wird von diesen
Subventionen nichts angekommen das ist
einfach noch Perversität das ist die
Solidarität aller Ampel
es drängt sich der Verdacht auf dass der
Wirtschaftsminister keine große Ahnung
von den Energie- und Wärmeerzeugung
dieser Nation hat und dazu passt auch
die Kommission für erdgossen und Wärme
hier an dieser Stelle ein Zitat des
Präsidenten von Haus und Grund Zitat die
Vorschläge wirken als wären sie von
Leuten erarbeitet worden die noch nie
eine Heizkostenabrechnung gesehen
geschweige denn erarbeitet haben Zitate
erinnert das sagt alles aus ihre
Kommission ist die grindeler Grimm der
bundesrepublikanischen Lebenslügen und
parteibuchwirtschaft eine absurde
Mischung aus klima-logisten
Gewerkschaftlern Vertretern der
Energieversorger und nicht zuletzt der
Caritas diktiert diese Regierung nun die
Energiepolitik
obwohl also diese Regierung doch diese
ungenügende Maßnahmen eingesteht dass
wir eine Energiekrise haben ist sie
nicht willens durch eine Mehrproduktion
von Energie diese Krise entgegenzuwirken
und zwar aus rein ideologischen Gründen
wir haben zu wenig Energie sie warnen
bereits vor dem Winter 23 24 verzichten
aber generös auf viele Gigawatt an
Leistung aus Kern und Kohlekraftwerken
ihre Energiepolitik bewegt sich jenseits
der Grenzen des Wahnsinns um der
drohnen-knappheit im kommenden Winter zu
begegnen plant diese Regierung
keinesfalls mehr Energie zu erzeugen um
die Knappheit zu bekämpfen sondern mit
Hilfe von Steuermilliarden den
energiehändlern das knappe Gut Gas zu
vergolden und in europäischen Preiskampf
endgültig eskalieren zu lassen die
Regierung kapituliert dabei nicht nur
vor der mangel-lager sondern sie hat
diese verursacht der Grund dafür liegt
in der stasinigkeit der Regierung die
einfach nicht akzeptieren will sich in
der Frage des Kernkraft und
kohleausstieges fundamental geirrt zu
haben
und für diesen irrationalen starren
müssen die Bürger nun Milliarden ihre
Ersparnisse Opfern kommende Generationen
Erben die Schulden dieses
regierungsversagens Unternehmen droht
das Ende am Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und die die sich das alles
dann doch nicht leisten können werden im
Winter frieren vielleicht sogar hungern
die Bürger und Unternehmen in diesem
Land haben also zuerst den Schaden doch
überborden der Energiepreise dann ist
Sport einer politischen Nomenklatur
die selbstverschuldenden Probleme mit
Bergen und Bergen von Steuergeld
zuschütten
der Kollege Dr Lukas Köhler spricht
jetzt für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vielleicht zu
Beginn ein paar Grundlagen ich glaube
die gehen die Debatte öfters mal unter
das eine ist wir wissen es gibt einen
Krieg Puddings gegen Ukraine es gibt
aber gleichzeitig und das muss man immer
zu Anfang auch einmal bedenken ein
energiekrieg Putins gegen Europa und das
ist die Grundlage dieser Probleme und
das ist das was wir lösen müssen und dem
müssen wir entgegentreten und ich weiß
die AFD vergisst das immer sehr gerne
dass eben Putin das Problem ist aus
näherer Beziehung oder Freundschaft aber
ich glaube das muss man damit weit und
Zusagen und mitdenken
ich möchte
also ich habe aufgegeben zu versuchen
der AFD zu verstehen zu geben was
passiert dass der Zug abgefahren aber
zumindestens zwei Sachen Herr Kollege
wollte ich schon noch einmal mitgeben ah
der Vorschlag der gaskommission ist noch
nicht der Vorschlag der Bundesregierung
sondern eben der der gaskommission haben
Experten und Experten wins auch die
ganzen Versorger die exakt diese
Gasrechnung geschrieben haben und die
alle da dabei saßen einen solchen
Vorschlag vorgelegt ich bin also etwas
überrascht dass sie anscheinend haben
sie selber schon Gasrechnungen
geschrieben ich bin überrascht dass Sie
das hier einfach das zweite ist
und das ist glaube ich wichtig was
dieser Vorschlag macht ist er schaut
sich explizit den gaspreiser und die
Wärmeversorgung also Gas und Fernwärme
Strom Strompreis Bremse kommt noch die
Art und Weise wie wir mit Öl und Pellets
umgehen auch das wird von der Kommission
besprochen und weiter erarbeitet und
auch da kommen vorschlägt aber man muss
es glaube ich einmal auseinander und ich
helfe da auch gerne der
oppositionellen Demenz der Union ein
bisschen auf die Sprünge Herr junges
Klang eben so als ob das jetzt die
einzigen Maßnahmen werden die diese
Bundesregierung auf den Weg bringen
würde und die einzigen Maßnahmen die wir
hier im Parlament schon längst
beschlossen hätten nein mitnichten ist
das der Fall wir haben 96 Milliarden
Euro jetzt schon also zusätzlich zu den
200 Milliarden in die Hand genommen um
zielgerichtet die Menschen über diesen
Winter zu bringen um den Unternehmen zu
helfen um alles dafür zu tun das auch
die Leute nicht nur die mit keinem
Einkommen Weiterkommen sondern auch zum
Beispiel über die kalte Progression
dafür gesorgt dass die Menschen mit
mittleren Einkommen auch vor der
Inflation geschützt werden und das darf
und muss man mit nennen wenn man darüber
spricht wir haben auch dafür gesorgt um
die Kollegin Kalender hat zum Glück ja
schon angesprochen dafür gesorgt dass
die Speicherstände auf 92 93 Prozent
hochgehen konnten dafür haben wir
gesorgt damit wir gut über diesen Winter
kommen und das ist ein wahrlicher Erfolg
genauso sorgen wir dafür gesetzlich dass
die Kohlekraftwerke jetzt in großem Maß
ans Netz gehen und über die
Kernkraftwerke da diskutieren wir gerade
und da bin ich mir sehr sicher dass das
sehr zeitnah zu einer Lösung kommt
die Frage die wir uns stellen müssen bei
der Bewertung dieses Konzepts dass die
gaskommission vorschlägt und da auch
noch mal vielen Dank an diese Kommission
die das wirklich finde ich sehr sehr gut
erarbeitet hat ist wir brauchen einen
Instrument oder wir brauchen mehrere
Instrumente die drei Kriterien a müssen
Sie schnell und einfach wirken sie
müssen so schnell es geht bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern aber auch bei
den Unternehmen bei den Bäckern bei den
Mittelständlern bei den Handwerkern aber
auch in der Industrie ankommen 1 Nummer
2 ist sie müssen unbürokratisch sein sie
müssen möglichst einfach akzeptiert
werden aber vor allen Dingen müssen Sie
einfach bei den Leuten und den
Unternehmen ankommen und Nummer drei und
das ist absolut zentral sie dürfen dabei
nicht den Spar Anreiz über den Jordan
gehen lassen warum weil wenn wir nicht
mehr einsparen passieren zwei Dinge
zunächst subventionieren wir gegen die
Knappheit also gegen zu wenig Gas an das
bedeutet dann dass das Geld dass wir
staatlich in die Hand nehmen würden gar
nicht mehr bei den Menschen ankommt weil
ja der
Preis der Großhandelspreis immer teurer
werden und das ist ein Problem und
zweitens ist wenn wir nicht genug sparen
meine Damen und Herren dann haben wir
eine gasmangelage dann reden wir nicht
mehr über gaspreisbremsen dann reden wir
darüber dass die Bundesnetzagentur
zuweist wer wie viel Gas bekommt und das
ist eine Situation die wir um jeden
Preis verhindern müssen weil das ist der
wirtschaftliche Abgesang dieses Landes
und deswegen ist der spar-anreiz und der
ist in diesem Vorschlag drin sehr sehr
wichtig
jetzt kann man sich fragen warum
schafft die gaskommission diese
Rahmenbedingungen und ja das tut sie sie
sorgt dafür dass wir mit den 80 Prozent
in den Haushalten und den 70% bei den
Industrieunternehmen sparen reizen
lassen sie sorgt dafür dass insbesondere
die Industrie die einen größeren Teil
Schuld hat jetzt schon an sparen ein
Einsparung aber auch in Zukunft
Schultern wird das Gas dass sie auch mit
staatlicher Unterstützung bekommt weiter
handeln kann so dass da der sparanreiz
ganz klar bestehen bleibt und deswegen
ist das ein guter Vorschlag es ist eine
gute Idee so vorzugehen was aber fehlt
sind die drei wesentlichen Punkte das
zum einen das was wir jetzt diskutieren
müssen über wie sieht eine Zukunft aus
in der der lng-preis in Deutschland die
Strom- und Gaskosten setzen und das ist
die Zukunft in drei vier fünf Jahren da
müssen wir heute darüber nachdenken wie
das aussehen wird damit wir vorbereitet
sind aber das Gute ist da sprechen wir
sowohl mit dem Ministerium als auch in
den Fraktion das zweite ist dass wir
natürlich jetzt über Strom nachdenken
müssen da kommt analog zu diesem
Vorschlag sehr bald der Vorschlag aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium damit ich mir
sicher und der letzte Punkt ist der
allerletzte Punkt ist die Frage wie wir
mit den anderen Heizkosten umgehen und
auch die werden senken ich bin mir
sicher dass ein sehr guter Vorschlag
vielen herzlichen Dank
ja Lukas Köhler hat es auch gleich zu
Beginn seiner Rede gesagt das sind
Empfehlungen der Expertenkommission das
ist noch kein Gesetz
also die konkrete Umsetzung da muss man
dann normal schauen wie das genau
aussieht Dietmar Bartsch ist für die
Linke der fraktionsvorsitze Aktuelle
Stunde sondern wirklich eine
Regierungserklärung zu diesem Problem
gewünscht das wäre sinnvoll gewesen wir
alle wissen doch dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und die Betriebe in unserem
Land aufgrund der explodierenden Preise
mit dem Rücken zur Wand stehen das ist
uns allen hier bekannt und immer mehr
Menschen fragen sich wie sollen sie denn
diese Krise stemmen und ehrlich gesagt
Herr Köhler es ist nicht die einzige
Maßnahme das ist wahr nur die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben immer mehr
das Gefühl dass es zugeht wie auf dem
Basar was sie gerade zum Beispiel bei
der atomkraftveranstalten das ist doch
der Wahnsinn das sind parteipolitische
Ränkespiele das ist geschafft mal es
geht nicht mehr um die Sache das ist das
Problem und der Kanzler duckt sich weg
der muss Therapiegespräche mit Herrn
Linder und Herrn Harbeck führen deswegen
sind die offensichtlich alle nicht da
das ist das Problem die Menschen draußen
erfahren was anderes als das was sie
hier darlegen seit Monaten explodieren
die Gaspreise die Bürger die bekommen
teilweise Rechnungen da denken Sie
zunächst diesen Druckfehler aber das ist
die Realität wir stehen vor der größten
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen Krise der
Nachkriegszeit meine Damen und Herren
das ist die Realität und der
Bundeskanzler beschwörtern you never
walk alone und Wumms und doppelwumms und
Bazooka die Realität immer weiter
steigende Preise und immer weiter
wachsende Unzufriedenheit im Land meine
Damen und Herren das was wir heute hier
diskutieren was sie diskutieren das
hätte im Juni diskutiert werden müssen
und vor allen Dingen entschieden werden
müssen ich habe hier dreimal das Wort
schnell gehört ich dachte ich höre nicht
richtig das ist ihm nicht schnell
gewesen zu Beginn der Heizsaison im
Oktober hätte das vorliegen müssen und
die gaspreisbremse gelten müssen das
wäre richtig lieber Matthias Mörsch und
nicht erst im März was ist denn die
Realität gewesen
dass hier bis vor kurzem noch über eine
vermurkste gaspreisumlage geredet worden
ist ich erinnere mich noch an den
Wirtschaftsminister die muss weg
Opposition na was ist denn das für ein
agieren das ist das Problem sie haben
untereinander über Monate gestritten und
sich um die Menschen nur beiläufig
gekümmert und das ist verantwortungslos
sie sind eine zu spätkoalition meine
Damen und Herren das ist alles nach dem
Motto von Mark Twain nach dem Motto von
maxwain verschiebe nicht auf morgen was
du auch übermorgen kannst besorgen das
ist leider die Wahrheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt soll die
gaspreisbremse im März kommen
sie tritt für private also und Kraft
wenn die Saison vorbei ist das habe ich
doch richtig verstanden die Heizsaison
wesentlich vorbei ist wie absurd ist das
eigentlich und ich bin ja sehr froh
Matthias Mörsch das du sagst ja wir bin
auch sehr einverstanden wir müssen weit
über weitere Maßnahmen nachdenken da bin
ich sehr gespannt nämlich sehr gespannt
die mich dann gerne sehen deswegen lasse
ich das jetzt mal offen weil es denn
wenn das so stehen bleiben dann ist es
eine Zumutung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ich hoffe dass es wirklich
weitere Maßnahmen geht und dann liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt kommt der
Punkt die erste Stufe soll dann heißen
im Dezember wird die Gasrechnung für
alle übernommen ehrlich gesagt was heißt
denn das das heißt wenn eine Villa mit
Pool hat und acht Zimmern und richtig
mollig warmheizt der bekommt einen
fetten Rabatt vom Steuerzahler und die
Rentnerin die schon über Jahre gespart
hat und eine kleine Wohnung hat die
bekommen fast nichts das meine Damen und
Herren ist nicht gerecht wir ich kann
nur der Koalition sagen Millionäre und
übrigens auch Minister wir brauchen
keine Hilfe das ist eine absurde das ist
eine unsoziale Gießkanne was sie hier
vorschlagen sie sind nicht nur die zu
spät Koalition sie sind
auch Koalition meine Damen und Herren
ich will jetzt über die Strom und die
Spritpreise nicht weiter reden es droht
ihre
gaspreisbremse zu einer Luftnummer zu
werden und deswegen sehr einverstanden
sie muss dringend parlamentarisch
nachgearbeitet werden ja ausdrücklich
wir sind bereit da konstruktiv uns
einzubringen überhaupt keine Frage nur
der jetzige Vorschlag der ist wirklich
zutiefst sozial ungerecht ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen weil sie ja noch Vorschläge
rufen wir haben immer gesagt ein
grundton-kontingent was wir vorschlagen
8000 Kilowatt pro Haushalt 4.000
Kilowatt für jedes weitere Mitglied
Haushaltsmitglied preislich auf
Vorjahresniveau Deckeln damit könnten
die Familien planen und dann würden sie
auch deutlich entlastet werden meine
Damen und Herren aber
als zu spätkoalition und sozial
ungerecht Koalition betreiben sie halt
viel zu viel machtpolitische Spiele und
führen das Land damit nicht durch die
Krise nehmen sie endlich ihre
Verantwortung wahr und dabei müssen die
Menschen im Mittelpunkt stehen nicht die
Konzerne für die ist das eher vernünftig
für viele Menschen nicht herzlichen Dank
der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
Linksfraktion hier in dieser aktuellen
Stunde beantragt ja von den Fraktionen
der Ampelkoalition
für die SPD hören wir jetzt Nina Schere
die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja Herr Bartsch
wenn sie jetzt gerade aufgezählt haben
was sie alles an den Konzepten vermissen
die ja wohl bemerkt erst mal erste
Vorschläge sind das sind ja noch nicht
mal die Konzepte sind erste Vorschläge
und es ist jetzt der Bereich einer
weiteren Bereich an in einer Reihe von
sehr sehr vielen Maßnahmen die wir schon
beschlossen haben das unterschlagen sie
dabei auch immer aber wenn sie dann
schon jetzt auf vermeintliches fehlen
abstellen ich habe jetzt bei ihnen nicht
herausgehört dass bei ihren
oberflächlich dargestellten Vorschlägen
jetzt nicht die willenbesitzer
profitiert hätten habe ich nicht
rausgehört also insofern es ist
natürlich genau bei Ihnen genau das
gleiche Problem wie bei uns allen wenn
wir Maßnahmen schnell machen wollen und
ich will ihnen gar nicht absprechen dass
sie das wirklich auch beabsichtigen dass
dann man
Schwierigkeiten bekommt ist wirklich
ganz zielgenau zu machen das ist einfach
das Hauptproblem was wir alle haben und
es ist einfach unredlich in Diskussionen
wie den hiesigen angesichts dieser so
dramatischen Situation immer wieder zu
unterstellen und zu suggerieren vor der
Öffentlichkeit zu suggerieren dass
dieses Problem nicht existieren würde
das ist unredlich und deswegen möchte
ich hier darauf nochmal Hinweisen
natürlich ist das Hauptproblem was wir
haben zur Ausgestaltung dieser
gaspreisbremse und auch weiterer Hilfen
das war schon das ganze Jahr über die
Herausforderung dass wir einerseits
schnell die Menschen entlasten wollen
das haben wir auch getan einmal mit 30
Milliarden dann nochmal mit 60
Milliarden wir haben jetzt schon
beschlossen über 95 Milliarden jetzt
noch mal den Abwehrschirm mit 200
Milliarden für die nächsten Jahre
gestreckt und bei all den Maßnahmen ist
immer die gleiche Herausforderung wir
wollen es möglichst schnell hinbekommen
haben es bisher immer schnell geschafft
aber es muss zielgerichtet sein und
deswegen haben wir natürlich vor das
auch
Steuerungsinstrumente als das ist
versteuert werden soll damit eben nicht
die Reichen überproportional davon
profitieren sondern weniger davon
profitieren das ist natürlich an die
Bedürftigen zu allererst gehen soll und
natürlich haben wir längst auf dem
Schirm das ist nicht nur gasleitungs
aktuell Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
gibt es gibt auch Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher die Tanks haben die an Öl
hängen die mit Holzpellets halten
natürlich gibt es die aber wir müssen
natürlich schauen dass das Maß an
Überforderung was wir haben also dass
die Menschen nicht überfordert werden
dass dieses Maß für uns maßgeblich ist
und es darf dann nicht zu einer
überproportionalen Überforderung von
anderen kommen sondern es muss wirklich
gerecht zu gehen alle müssen
gleichermaßen entlastet werden am
Maßstab ihrer Überforderung und genau
das wird die Ausgestaltung unserer
Arbeit sein die nächsten Wochen
zudem ist natürlich auch klar wenn man
eben dazu übergehen wird dann diese
Stufe auszugestalten dass ein bestimmter
Prozentsatz vom Jahresverbrauch dann in
einer gaspreisbremse sich wiederfindet
dass man da natürlich auch schaut ja das
ist erstmal schon ein großer
einsparanreiz wenn man mit Prozenten
eines Jahresverbrauchs Arbeit ist das
schon mal ein guter einsparanreiz aber
wir sind frei darin und es liegen die
Konzepte auf dem Tisch natürlich auch
weitergehende Anreize zu geben weil wir
wissen natürlich dass Anreize bzw
Einsparen von Gas nicht nur die
individuelle Rechnung runterdrückt
sondern jedes eingesparte Gas das jetzt
nicht dazu gekauft werden muss ist eine
Entlastung für alle weil einfach die
Preise so rennt hoch sind deswegen ist
das natürlich auch etwas was überprüft
wird
[Applaus]
und natürlich auch klare Obergrenzen es
kann nicht sein dass man sagt es werden
einfach angemessen am Verbrauch bis ins
Uferlose weil dann wäre natürlich
tatsächlich auch die Leute noch weiter
und die VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher
noch weiter
auch fördern die die einfach aufgrund
ihrer Bedarfssituation sehr viel Energie
bisher verbraucht haben und selbst bei
einem verminderten Anteil wäre das nicht
das richtige Signal deswegen braucht man
natürlich auch eine Obergrenze bei der
Unterstützung weil sonst würde auch dies
nicht zielgerichtet funktionieren
ich möchte ganz zum Schluss aber noch
mal auf zwei Punkte eingehen und zwar
eine ganz wichtige
Aufgabenstellung wird hierbei auch sein
dass wir bei all den Notfallmaßnahmen
die wir jetzt erneut auf den Weg bringen
und die natürlich
flankieren dass wir eine fossile
energiepreiskrise haben dass dabei diese
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen nicht bewirken
dass wir die erneuerbaren Energien
zurückdrängen das darf nicht passieren
es muss nach wie vor ein stärkerer
Anreiz sein und eine Privilegierung für
erneuerbare Energien sein also wir
müssen gar sehr genau darauf achten dass
diese Privilegierung die wir auch
gesetzlich verankert haben dass die bei
all dem erhalten bleibt da darf keine
Überforderung in eine Richtung gehen die
uns von diesem Pfad abbringt weil dies
würde die Menschen auf mittel und
längerfristige Sicht massiv belasten
wenn wir Ihnen die Möglichkeit nehmen
schnellstmöglich auf erneuerbare
Energien umzusteigen vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege Dr Andreas Lenz ist jetzt
der nächste Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Kommission
Gas hat ihre Ergebnisse vorgelegt und
auch ich möchte mich ganz herzlich dafür
bedanken letzten Endes wurde ich hier ja
Arbeit gemacht die eigentlich die
Regierung leisten muss und dass die
Opposition hier nicht involviert war das
hatten wir zwar bedauert aber wir freuen
uns natürlich auch dass viele dass viele
unserer Vorschläge sich wiederfinden in
den entsprechenden Entwürfen der
gaskommission und das sage nicht nur ich
das sagt auch die Frau Professor Grimm
heute im Handelsblatt und V Professor
Grimm bedauert auch dass diese
Kommission nicht früher eingesetzt wurde
und das bedauern wir auch wir haben
unsere Vorschläge Teil des Sommer
entsprechend vorliegen wir haben noch im
September einen Antrag zur Abstimmung
stellen wollen wo wir eine
Preisbremse für Gas gefordert hatten wo
wir einen
bürgerbasiskreis gefordert hatten und wo
wir außerdem Anreize zum Energiesparen
entsprechend auch setzen wollten eine
energiepauschale von 1000 Euro für
untere einkommensdrittel leider hat
damals die SPD die Grünen und die FDP
nicht zugestimmt und schon Anfang 22
Anfang diesen Jahres hat die CSU
übrigens eine
gaspreisdeckelung gefordert einen
Budgetansatz und die Ampel schaltet also
einmal wieder zu spät zu langsam sie
waren den ganzen Sommer mit einem
gasumlage-chaos beschäftigt sie können
die Entlastungen sie könnten die
Entlassungen jetzt schon einführen wenn
sie entsprechend nicht die Zahl vertutet
hätten und dann würde eben auch die
Entlastung nicht erst im April nächsten
Jahres gelten sondern schon jetzt und
wie gesagt das geht auf Ihr Konto
im April ist schließlich die Heizperiode
weitestgehend vorbei dann erst greifen
eine Vielzahl der entsprechenden
Entlastungen im April kann es für viele
Unternehmen aber bereits zu spät sein
das geht wie gesagt alles auf Ihr Konto
auf ihre Untätigkeit und jetzt mal
konkret zu den Vorschlägen der
Mittelstand soll zukünftig 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde Gas Zahlen genauso viel
wie die Verbraucher das ist natürlich
gut weil es eine Reduzierung ist aber
jetzt ist es so wenn ich die Vorschläge
entsprechend zu Ende lese dann könnte
das bedeuten dass der Bäcker zukünftig
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde Zeit das aber
der Großbäcker 7 Cent zahlt und es geht
doch nicht zusammen das benachteiligt
doch den Mittelstand des benachteiligt
doch gerade auf die kleinen gegenüber
die großen
und übrigens entlastet die SPD den
Gaspreis des
einkommensmillionärs das muss man ja
auch mal sich vergegenwärtigen wie das
entsprechend erklärt werden soll da bin
ich noch gespannt wohin gegen die
niedrigen Einkommen letzten Endes nur
mit einem gießkännchen entlastet werden
sollen das ist weder sozial noch gerecht
und da muss einen doch lieber Matthias
Mirsch dann muss ein doch das Herz eines
aufrechten Sozialdemokraten entsprechend
bluten und gleichzeitig und gleichzeitig
werden die Haushalte die unter hohen
Preisen die unter hohen Preisen für
Heizöl und Pellets leiden nicht
entlastet die passendes zusammen das
passt überhaupt nicht zusammen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
die die Reduzierung des Gaspreises pro
Kilowattstunde um einen Cent kostet pro
Jahr acht bis zehn Milliarden Euro das
ist enorm und das ist dauerhaft auch
nicht zu leisten umso wichtiger ist es
dass jetzt alle Ressourcen auf der
Angebotsseite entsprechend auch wirklich
genutzt werden nutzbar gemacht werden
wir brauchen der Schatz
ersatzbeschaffungsmaßnahmen da wird viel
gesprochen aber wenig geliefert im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und übrigens
auch was den Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke betrifft brauchen wir
jetzt wirkliche Planungssicherheit
brauchen auch die Betreiber
entsprechende Planungssicherheit und da
liefern sich Lindner und Habeck einen
einen Schaukampf auf offener Bühne das
ist nicht verantwortungsvoll meine Damen
und Herren und letzten Endes ist es doch
so je höher das Angebot ist je höher das
Angebot ist desto niedriger ist der
Preis und das ist auch die günstigste
Form und entsprechend die Preise auch zu
senken
ja wir brauchen schnell Ergebnisse und
die Vorschläge sind noch längst nicht
umgesetzt es geht jetzt wirklich schnell
zu tun auch zielgenau zu machen
unbürokratisch zu machen und wir hoffen
sehr dass es kein wir hoffen sehr dass
es kein nächstes hier bei der gasumlage
entsprechend gibt damit wäre niemanden
geholfen also fordern wir fordern sie
auf handeln sie wirklich schnell und
handeln Sie zielgerichtet sonst ist es
für viele in diesem Land zu spät
herzlichen Dank
ja die Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm
eine der Vorsitzenden der
Expertenkommission die hätte sich
tatsächlich etwas mehr Zeit gewünscht
für die Vorschläge bis 6:30 Uhr Montag
früh hatte die Expertenkommission ja
sozusagen eine Klausur an diesem
Wochenende um dann diese Vorschläge um
diesen Zwischenbericht vorzulegen Dieter
janitschek jetzt für die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
der Abwehrschirm den die Menschen in der
Ukraine bräuchten ist einer vor den
schrecklichen Angriffskrieg der
russischen Armee mit Bomben wir
diskutieren heute über den Abwehrschirm
für unsere Volkswirtschaft für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für kleine
mittelständische Unternehmen das ist
wichtig aber es ist auch wichtig dass in
den Kontext zu stellen wir sind deswegen
heute hier weil Russland weil Putin in
der Ukraine diesen schrecklichen Krieg
führt
ich möchte mich bedanken bei den
Mitgliedern der unabhängigen Kommission
Erdgas und Wärme ich finde sie haben
kluge Vorschläge geliefert natürlich
sind wir jetzt gefordert im Verfahren
diese zu bewerten und auch noch zu
prüfen der mir statt zu Recht über die
sozialen Auswirkungen für den Einzelnen
aber erst einmal grundsätzlich ist eine
Botschaft ganz wichtig wir haben als
Bundesregierung als Koalition vorgesorgt
wir kommen gut durch den Winter vor
allem wenn wir auch kraftvoll weiter
daran arbeiten Energie einzusparen auf
der anderen Seite Angebot auszuweiten
und die Maßnahmen die wir jetzt bei der
Entlastung machen auch kräftig zu
vollziehen das heißt wir haben eine
klare Kursreaktion der geschaffen und
das ist entscheidend dass wir gut durch
den Winter kommen
wenn man sich die Vorschläge jetzt
anschaut ist ja der Einspareffekt
vorgesehen die Industrie soll nach
Vorschlägen von Frau Grimm und anderen
Professor Grimm
jetzt 70 Prozent ihres Verbrauchs aufs
Verbrauchs der 21 gedeckelt bekommen und
dafür einen Beschaffungspreis von 7 Cent
und lieber Andreas Lenz das eine ist der
Beschaffungspreis 7 Cent das andere ist
der garantierte Verbrauchspreis da
kommen nämlich noch Netzentgelt andere
Sachen drauf ich glaube das wissen sie
ziemlich genau deswegen ist die
Spreizung des zwischen dem
Industriepreis und dem Mittelstandspreis
nicht so hoch wie Sie tun kann im
Einzelfall sogar gleich sein also das
ist einfach eine Frage wo man ansetzt
diese 70 Prozent heißen aber auch dass
weiter eingespart werden mussten so ist
es auch bei den Verbrauchern wir können
den Menschen ja nicht sagen und deswegen
halte ich es auch für richtig dass wir
nicht jetzt rückwirkend Maßnahmen
beschlossen aber bei der Entlastung
sondern dass wir sagen es gibt jetzt
eine Einmalzahlung damit bitte
investiert die wenn ihr müsst auch in
eure Ausgaben die ihr habt auf der
Gasseite auf der stromseite aber bitte
spart auch einen diesen Winter so weit
ihr das könnt und das ist eine ganz
wesentliche Botschaft denn Lukas Köhler
hat das völlig zurecht gesagt das
schlimmste Szenario was wir haben können
ist dass wir durch eine erhöhten
Verbrauch doch noch in eine gasmangel
Lage kommen dann haben wir wirklich mit
Zitronen gehandelt und dann sind wir in
der veritablen Wirtschaftskrise die wir
nicht mehr aufhalten können
jetzt ist ja die Frage auch was wir
lernen können aus dem Prozessen eins
können wir lernen als wir die Regierung
übernommen haben fehlten uns viele Daten
zum Beispiel bei den Gas Verbräuchen der
Wenzel weiß das genau uns fehlen heute
noch die Daten wie wir beispielsweise
Einmalzahlungen übertragen können also
dieses Thematik von
Entlastungsmöglichkeiten Christian
Lindner weiß das auch daran wird
gearbeitet dass das mit der Zukunft
besser ist damit man Instrumente zur
Verfügung hat und zu reagieren die wir
heute nicht haben deswegen sind
bestimmte Maßnahmen die wir heute
tätigen eben auch davon abhängig wie wir
sie realisieren können auch das gehört
zu Wahrheit und deswegen ist dieser
Punkt der Einmalzahlung im Dezember
jetzt ein richtiger und wichtiger weil
er unbürokratisch ist den Menschen etwas
in die Hand gibt dass sie durch den
Winter kommen aber das klare Signal dann
auch dass am Ende des Winters ein
garantierter Preis auf Gas und Strom und
ich denke bei Strom werden wir analog
Handeln zur Verfügung steht das schafft
Planungssicherheit für die Industrie für
die Wirtschaft für die Kunden für die
Verbraucher und das ist dass wir in dem
Gesamtkontext gehandelt haben mit den 95
Milliarden Euro die wir jetzt schon
Entlastung handeln das ist eine
Strategie und die lässt sich sehen und
die ist richtig in dieser ökonomisch
sinnvoll und es ist übrigens auch
sinnvoll zu sagen dass wir jetzt die
Inflation dadurch bekämpfen denn wenn
wir die Preise senken wird die Inflation
auch runtergehen sein erster Schritt sie
wird noch nicht unter fünf Prozent
kommen nächstes Jahr aber wir nächstes
Mal auf sieben auch das ist ein Schritt
den wir tun also das ist alles
durchdacht und dessen eine gute
Strategie die die Koalition hier
vorliegt
jetzt ist die Frage immer natürlich kann
man es allen Recht machen nein ist
ehrlich man kann es nicht allen recht
machen das ist auch die Aussage der
Kommission sie können keine
einzelfallgerechte Maßnahme in einem
Vorschlag unterbringen wenn jemand zum
Beispiel beim Thema Heizöl einen
Heizöltank voll gemacht hat im letzten
Winter zu den alten kosten dann hat er
den vielleicht jetzt noch für den
nächsten Winter solche Kessel gibt es ja
dann hat er die alten Preise wenn er
jemand jetzt jemand gekauft hat für 150
Euro hat er höhere Kosten wie soll ich
darauf als Staat reagieren durch
Entlastung für die Allgemeinheit aber
ich kann das nicht fallbezogen
entscheiden und deswegen das Signal der
Debatte ist heute das ist ein guter
Vorschlag den schauen wir uns jetzt an
wir werden da zügig entscheiden wir
werden nach sozialen Kriterien auch
entlasten aber nochmal wir kommen durch
den Winter gut das ist schon mal die
Signal was wir durch die Arbeit der
Bundesregierung der letzten Monate
gegeben haben Gasspeicher voll in den
Terminals kommen Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien aber entscheidend sparen wir
gemeinsam Energie ein das ist
entscheidend um gut durch den Winter zu
kommen und entscheidend auch für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
Industrie vielen Dank ja das normal der
Appell von Dieter Janecek
der Energieeinsparen
bleibt natürlich auch ein Gebot dieses
Winters Michael Kruse jetzt für die FDP
der nächste hier am Rednerpult
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind ja nun
mal im Bereich der Energie in eine große
Abhängigkeit geraten und deswegen ist es
unser Ziel als Regierung und als
regierungstragende Fraktion aus dieser
Abhängigkeit schnellstmöglich
rauszukommen und wieder in der
Energieunabhängigkeit zu kommen und mit
Abhängigkeit und Entzug der Ressource
bei der hier die Abhängigkeit besonders
groß ist das ist das Gas entstehen nicht
nur jede Menge gesetzgeberische
Aktivitäten sondern es steht bei
entsteht bei einem großen Teil der
Wirtschaft und der Bevölkerung große
Sorge und hier kommt Politik ins Spiel
wir haben die Möglichkeiten Sorgen zu
vergrößern oder wir haben die
Möglichkeiten Sorgen ernst zu nehmen und
mit Lösungen daran zu arbeiten dass wir
sie in den Griff bekommen und dass wir
die Probleme die sie sorgen begründen
lösen wenn Sie hier am Rand sitzen dann
waren sie auch heute in der Debatte
wieder damit beschäftigt auf sorgen
drauf zu satteln sie zu vergrößern sie
herbeizureden viel Zeit darauf zu
verwenden zu beschreiben warum man sich
diese Sorgen machen muss und warum die
Regierung mich handelt oder Sie setzen
hier eher in der Mitte des Hauses und
wenn sie in der Mitte des Hauses sitzen
dann sind sie so wie wir damit
beschäftigt Lösungen zu erarbeiten um
den Menschen in diesem Land die Sorgen
zu nehmen das ist unsere Aufgabe als
verantwortungsvolle Politikerinnen und
Politiker
und genau solche Lösungen genau solche
Lösungen hat die Kommission in ziemlich
hoher Geschwindigkeit erarbeitet und
dafür gebührt ihr Dank und Respekt und
das ist etwas was wir anerkennen
inhaltlich haben wir ja schon einiges
gehört heute wir haben wichtige Ziele
die es zu erreichen gilt mit diesem
maßnahmen-set wir müssen die
spar-anreize hochhalten wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass unsere konkrete Gesetzgebung
fair ausgestaltet ist wir wollen eine
schnelle Umsetzung und wir wollen eine
unbürokratische Umsetzung die Messlatte
liegt hoch und ich kann Ihnen
versprechen wir werden über diese Latte
springen
und mit dem klaren Zielen die wir hier
formulieren mit den klaren Zielen die
wir hier formulieren nehmen wir den
Menschen ihre Sorgen nämlich ist die
größte Sorge das ist so schlimm bleiben
könnte wie es aktuell ist etwa dass die
Gaspreise so hoch bleiben könnten wie
sie in diesem Sommer gewesen sind und
deswegen ergreifen wir konkrete
Maßnahmen um aus der Abhängigkeit
rauszukommen und um damit auch die
Sorgen der Menschen in diesem Land in
den Griff zu kriegen ich nenne nun mal
die Themen lng-speicher wir haben sie
gefüllt das war unser erstes Gesetz im
März dieses Jahres heute sind wir über
94 Prozent wer hätte das ernsthaft
gedacht der Ausbau der lng-terminals in
einer Rekordgeschwindigkeit
Wilhelmshaven 28 Kilometer Leitung sind
schon unterwegs eine einsparkampagne wie
sie dieses Land nicht erlebt hat und
natürlich in den aktuellen Tagen mit den
Sorgen um das was wir als Anschläge im
Moment sehen auch der Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur dieses alles
als Basis für die Versorgung der
Menschen in diesem Land und wenn man das
jetzt mal alles zusammen nimmt dann kann
man bestimmte Wirkprinzipien erkennen
die wir hier zur Anwendung bringen das
erste ist wir ein klares Ziel aus der
Energie Abhängigkeit rauskommt das
zweite ist ein großes Engagement und da
verstehe ich auch die Kritik der
Opposition ehrlich gesagt nicht denn
natürlich ist es gut die Versorger die
Ökonomen die Wissenschaftler alle mit am
Tisch zu haben um gemeinsam etwas zu
erarbeiten um gemeinsam das beste
Konzept zu erarbeiten und da verstehe
ich dann wirklich nicht was da
eigentlich die Kritik sein sollte
andersrum wenn wir uns das alles im
stillen Kämmerlein ausgedacht hätten
dann hätten sie doch einen Grund zur
Kritik wir haben hier mit dem größten
möglichen auch gesellschaftlichen
Engagement dafür gesorgt dass hier gute
Konzepte erarbeitet werden Klarheit
Engagement Geschwindigkeit und am Ende
produzieren diese drei Werte
Verlässlichkeit meine lieben Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und das wird auch schon
deutlich an den Märkten wir haben in
diesem Sommer Höchstpreise am Spotmarkt
für Gas von 320 Euro gesehen aktuell
schwanken wir um 100 Euro wir sind von
320 auf 100 Euro gefallen das ist das
Ergebnis einer Politik die in diesem
Land sichtbar wird und das ist immer
noch zu viel das möchte ich Ihnen sagen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
immer noch zu viel aber es ist nicht
mehr ruinös für unsere ganze
Volkswirtschaft und deswegen werden wir
diesen Weg auch weitergehen nämlich mit
verantwortungsvollen Maßnahmen den
Menschen in diesem Land ihre Sorgen zu
nehmen und wo Sorge gibt da gibt es auch
immer Hoffnung und ich frage mich bei
jedem einzelnen Redner und bei jeder
einzelnen Rednerin was tragen sie
eigentlich dazu bei den Menschen in
diesem Land in dieser schwierigen
Situation Hoffnung zu machen mit
entschlossenem Handeln mit beherztem
eingreifen und mit guten
gesetzgeberischen Maßnahmen werden wir
diese Hoffnung erarbeiten und deswegen
freue ich mich auf den weiteren
gesetzgeberischen Prozess zur
gaspreisbremse herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
für wahr dass der energiepolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion hier in der
Aktuellen Stunde zur gaspreiskommission
und ihren Vorschlägen als nächstes
spricht Julia Klöckner für die
Unionsfraktion sie ist die
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kollege
Kruse sie sprachen davon von Hoffnung
machen also eines kann ich Ihnen sagen
was den Bürgern keine Hoffnung gemacht
hat war ihr gereiere rund um die
gasumlage und wenn das Hoffnung machen
soll was Sie heute hier ich nenne es
jetzt mal eher ein Stuhlkreis der
Ampelkoalition zu den Ergebnissen dieser
Kommission es ist ja schon sehr
bezeichnend es ist ja Sie müssen auch
mal ertragen dass man sie kritisiert es
ist sehr sehr bezeichnend wie sie heute
hier reingehen dass sie von den
lng-speichern Sprachen die gefüllt sind
ich gehe davon aus dass das ein Fehler
war und nicht ihr Erkenntnisgewinn ist
sie haben von lng-speicher gesprochen um
die geht es hier nicht dann lassen wir
das dann stellen wir das einfach mal
klar aber es gehört ja auch dazu dass
wir den Sorgen der Menschen wirklich
auch Ernsthaftigkeit Entgegenkommen
lassen und der Bundeskanzler kommt
vielleicht so gerne zu uns ins Parlament
wie wir festgestellt haben wenn ich
jetzt wandern wäre Zeit für eine
Regierungserklärung damit er Kanzler
über die Lage in diesem Land einmal
spricht und auf einmal erklärt denn
was die Kollegin von den Grünen vorhin
sagte Frau Verlinden wir können nicht
von einem auf den anderen Tag zaubern
das verlangt auch keiner nur von Februar
bis Oktober kann man nicht von einem auf
den anderen Tag sprechen und zaubern
müssen Sie auch nicht dazwischen ist ein
Sommer gewesen wir haben ihnen angeboten
als
Oppositionsfraktion wir stehen parat und
kommen zu jeder Sondersitzung hierher
sie haben es vorgezogen über den Sommer
sich zu streiten sich auszutauschen zu
diskutieren hinzuhören und was machen
sie jetzt nachdem die Kommission ihren
Zwischenbericht vorgelegt hat wir
tauschen uns aus wir schauen uns das an
wir diskutieren das wissen Sie wofür und
wozu die Bürgerinnen und Bürger gar
keine Zeit haben zum Zuschauen zum
abwarten denn davon werden ihre
Rechnungen nicht bezahlt in diesem Land
und dass sie mal eine Vorstellung haben
wie es den vielen Unternehmen hier geht
in diesem Land die haben überhaupt nicht
ihre Zeit diese Unternehmen bei denen
laufen jetzt am Ende des Jahres die
Kontrakte die Verträge aus und diese
Verträge können Sie wenn Sie Glück haben
verlängern aber nicht zu einem Preis den
sie bisher kannten sondern zu einem
Vielfachen Preis ich habe ein
Unternehmer bei mir im Wahlkreis statt
700.000 Energiekosten Euro soll er im
nächsten Jahr 2,5 Millionen Euro zahlen
der braucht jetzt von Ihnen eine Antwort
bekommt er einen Zuschuss wenn ja
welchen was heißt das für ihn oder er
muss in die Insolvenz gehen wir haben
ein Drittel mehr Insolvenzen jetzt schon
im September wir haben keine Zeit und
das was sie wir machen gerade ist ein
Outsourcing von Verantwortung auf eine
Kommission diese Kommission hätten sie
einsetzen können im Frühjahr im Sommer
sie haben sie jetzt kurz vor Schluss
eingesetzt um dann wieder zu sagen wir
schauen uns das erst einmal an das ist
Verantwortungslosigkeit das ist
Outsourcing von Verantwortung und wir
schauen uns in Großbritannien wir
schauen uns in Frankreich an dort hat
man schon über eine Gas und
strompreisbremse entschieden sie wissen
noch nicht einmal gemeinsam zusammen wie
sie die Vorschläge dieser Kommission
beurteilen ich sage danke Frau Grimm ich
sage danke Herr Russwurm und sage auch
danke Herr Vassiliadis die mussten
nämlich unter einem so erheblichen
Zeitdruck ihnen etwas liefern und wir
hören die Koalition schweigen wo bleibt
denn ihr Fahrplan heute haben wir nichts
von einem Fahrplan gehört sondern wieder
das was wir die vergangenen Wochen
gehört haben sie diskutieren sie reden
sie schauen es sich an hier muss
gehandelt werden man braucht eine
Regierung die Krisen erkennt die anpackt
die nicht planlos ist sondern schnell
entscheidet und dass die Wirkung auch
ankommt und aus dem Grund schauen wir
uns doch mal die Zahlen an sie haben
einen
energiekosten-dämpfungsprogramm
aufgelegt wissen Sie wie viele da
überhaupt von profitiert haben heute im
Ausschuss haben wir die Zahl bekommen
28 Unternehmen in Deutschland sagen Sie
mir das ist doch ein Witz hier
und gerüttelt ab und zu aber wir haben
gehandelt ist Geld kam an und die Leute
hatten erstmal Luft zum Atmen das was
sie hier machen ist uns beschimpfen die
AKWs mit länger laufen zu lassen die
stromsteuern nicht so senken es gibt so
viele Dinge die sie jetzt machen könnten
und jetzt geht es um die
Angebotserweiterung damit der Strompreis
damit der Energiepreis auch sinkt
stattdessen lassen sie Gas weiterhin
verstromen das ist kein Konzept das ist
Spiele mit den Sorgen der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sie beschimpfen uns sie
machen nette öffentliche Darstellung
aber am Ende wird es darum gehen ob hier
Existenzen in Deutschland gesichert
werden und diese Kommission die ihre
Arbeit unter diesem Druck gemacht hat
übrigens Frau Grimm kann ihnen ihre
Expertise noch weiter einbringen sie
haben es nur nicht zugelassen Frau
Krämer kann Ihnen sehr gut berechnen was
es bedeutet wenn wir jetzt neue
Kernkraftwerk beziehungsweise die
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben erstmal
länger laufen lassen dass der Strompreis
dass der Preis sinkt das vor allen
Dingen die co2-schädlichen ausstoße
aussenken also kommen Sie uns gerade die
Grünen nicht mehr mit dem Thema Thema
Klimaschutz sie verbrennen lieber
Schweröl sie blasen lieber auch
Kohlekraft raus statt jetzt AKW länger
laufen zu lassen sie nehmen alle im
Geiselhaft nur für ihre parteipolitische
Ideologie und dafür ist dieses Land zu
schade dafür ist diese Frau Kollegin und
ich kann Ihnen nur sagen hier geht es um
Existenzen hier geht es darum dass
Menschen ihre Arbeit nicht verlieren
machen sie ihre Arbeit bitte
Julia Klöckner war das hier mit ihrer
Kritik an besonders der Schnelligkeit
oder eben zu langsam Schnelligkeit
eine Bundesregierung Michael schrodi
wird diese jetzt wohl eher verteidigen
er ist Mitglied der SPD-Fraktion
von diesen Bericht der Kommission geht
eine wichtige eine zentrale Botschaft
aus nach
milliardenschweren 100 Milliarden Euro
entlastungspaketen die wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben schon um kleine mittlere
Einkommen zu unterstützen nach einem
Abwehrschirm mit über 200 Milliarden
Euro den wir geschnürt haben haben wir
jetzt von dieser Kommission eine
Instrument eine gaspreisbremse
unterbreitet bekommen mit dem wir nicht
nur Kosten dämpfen sondern ein
systemeingriff vornehmen der den
Gaspreis auch massiv senken wird das
gibt den Menschen Sicherkeit das geht
wird Unternehmenssicherheit eine ganz
wichtige Signal in die Gesellschaft
hinein meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir lassen jemanden alleine und
Frau Glöckner von einer Fraktion
die seit dem Angriffskrieg Putins nur
zwei Dinge auf den Weg gebracht hat hier
in diesem Parlament das eine der
Vorschlag ein Gas embargo das nur die
Krise vertieft hätte und einen Antrag
Frau Klöckner zur Inflationsbekämpfung
der von den Experten verrissen wurde
nicht hilfreich ist alles zu spät
gekommen wäre lassen wir uns nicht sagen
die wir ständig dran sind und es auch
jetzt tun dieses Problem anzugehen sie
haben in ihrer Oppositionsrolle auch
Verantwortung
produktiv und substanziell ein Beitrag
zu leisten davon ist nichts zu spüren
bis heute nicht und daran müssen sie
auch messen lassen vor Klöckner wir
machen die Arbeit sie blöken nur und das
ist die falsche Sache die sie hier
angehen sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
ich habe auch jetzt im Moment keine
Alternative von ihnen gehört wo ist sie
denn wo ist Frau Glöckner
ein Alternative dazu wurden
Direktzahlungen wo denn dass der Preis
wirklich gesenkt wird es ist aber keine
Alternative nichts zu tun das können
sich reiche leisten aber die
gaspreisbremse so wie wir sie auf den
Weg bringen werden Hilfe allen den
Menschen mit kleinen mittleren Einkommen
weil sie kein finanziellen Puffer haben
weil sie keine Rücklagen haben weil sie
nicht sparen können und natürlich hilft
es dann wenn ich statt 12 Cent zur Stadt
28 Cent nur 12 Cent zahlen müssen das
hilft kleiner mittleren Einkommen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und es
hilft auch der Wirtschaft den kleinen
mittleren Unternehmen den
energieintensiven Industrie die unter
dem großen Kosten und Wettbewerbsdruck
stehen wenn wir jetzt auch da den
Preisdruck nehmen dieses Instrument
ist ein Schutz für die Wirtschaft für
Arbeitsplätze und für den sozialen
Zusammenhalt meine sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren deswegen werden wir in
zeitnah auf den Weg bringen
schnellstmöglich auf den Weg bringen
eine weitere wichtigen Effekt möchte ich
aber noch eingehen den diese
gaspreisbremse hat wenn wir die
Gaspreise wirklich senken und auch da
muss man sagen cdu/csu
kommen mit der Kritik diese
entlastungspakete der Abwehrschirm die
seine inflationstreibend wir würden Geld
in die Hand nehmen und
inflationstreibend Wirken der
Bundespräsident Nagel der bei uns im
Ausschuss war zuletzt im geldpolitischen
Dialog hat deutlich gemacht nein die
Maßnahmen gleichen die hohen Kosten
gleich die Kaufkraft aus kauft der
Verluste aus es ist nicht
inflationstreiben im Gegenteil und es
ist eine ganz wichtige Botschaft an die
Menschen draußen auch diese
gaspreisbremse senkt Produktionskosten
für Unternehmen sie senkt Preise für
Konsumenten sie sorgt für eine spürbare
sägung der Inflationsrate auch das ist
wichtig den Inflation ist eine soziale
Frage und diese gaspreisbremse wird
inflationsdämpfend wirken und hilft den
Menschen auch deshalb im Land und das
ist ein wichtiger Botschaft weil es sehr
Gärten Damen und Herren
zuletzt noch natürlich geht es auch um
die soziale Balance um die Gerechtigkeit
deswegen werden wir genau hinschauen wie
wir damit Einkommen wie wir damit
umgehen und welche Lösungen wir auch
dann haben das hohe Einkommen
besteuert werden dann auch wenn sie
solch ein Rabatt für Abschlagszahlungen
bekommen wie weit wir mit einer
Obergrenze für das gaskontingent auch
ein Instrument hier einziehen können
aber lassen wir noch auf eins eingehen
wir haben europäische Vereinbarungen
auch eine Verordnung jetzt und auch hier
national wir werden das auch umsetzen
eine strompreisbremse eine
gaspreisbremse
mit denen wir auch
diesen bedingte übergewinne abschöpfen
werden und dazu benutzen werden um die
Hilfsmaßnahmen alle Maßnahmen dann auch
mit so viel erzählt auch das ist eine
Frage der Gerechtigkeit dass die
Unternehmen die hohe krisenbedingte
Gewinne haben ihren Teile zu beitragen
und das werden wir ebenfalls national
und auch zeitnah Umsätze meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren das sind alles
konstruktive Beiträge diese apokalition
die wir Zeiten auf den Weg bringen
werden und ich würde mich freuen wenn
ich die Opposition dann auch einmal
konstruktiv und substanziell daran
beteiligen würden dankeschön
die Aktuelle Stunde ist damit beendet
und ich unterbreche die Sitzung bis 16
Uhr durch klingeln wird Ihnen in zwölf
Minuten angezeigt das ist weitergeht und
wir wollen Ihnen natürlich bis 16 Uhr 30
hier kein leeren Plenarsaal zeigen
sondern nutzen die Zeit sie über anderes
zu informieren